[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداثهم وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من محيط السد للبيت في العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه حيث ينطلق الشوط الثاني من
مباراه انجلترا والولايات المتحده ضمن
منافسات المجموعه الثانيه من المنتخبات
المشاركه في كاس العالم قطر
2022 هذه صور كثيره من رام الله بالضفه
الغربيه المحتله حيث يسوده جو من القلق من
اتفاق حزب الكود والحزب المعروف بالعظمه
اليهوديه الذي يمنح اليمنيه
وزاره الامن الداخلي في اسرائيل مع توسيعي
صلاحيتها
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
واستطرق لعمليه بريه تركيه في الشمال
السوري اردوغان يؤكد من جديد انه يريد
اقامه منطقه امنيه من الغرب الى الشرق
خارج حدود بلاده الجنوبيه
واشنطن تؤكد رفضها للضربات التركيه
الشماليه السوريه وتقول انها تهدد العمل
المشترك ضد تنظيم الدوله
الجنوب الاوكراني في مرمى القصف الروسي
اخلاء مستشفيات وتقارير عن سقوط قتل في
خرسون ملايين الاوكرانيين دون تدفئه او
كهرباء بعد ضربات جويه الروسيه
ستحقق اهدافها من العمليه العسكريه
والمانيا تبحث مع الحلفاء طلبات هولندا
تزويد اوكرانيا
التي كانت مخصصه لها
[موسيقى]
بعد اتفاق مع نتنياهو اليمني المتطرف بن
غفير وزيرا للامن الداخلي في الائتلاف
الحاكم المقبل في اسرائيل وفي خطبه غير
مسبوقه صلاحيات الوزاره تشمل المسؤوليه عن
شرطه الحدود في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وزير الدفاع في الحكومه الحاليه يصف
اتفاقا »
بالخطر الامني على اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه نقشت معكم اعلان الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان انا بلاده ستقيمه على
حدودها الجنوبيه مع سوريا حزاما امنيا من
الغرب الى الشرق في اقرب وقت ممكن واعت
ذلك اثر حديث تركيا انها ستسن في الوقت
المناسب وجوما بريا بموازته هجومها الجوي
على مواقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في شمال سوريا
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم قبل
قليل السؤال التالي الذي يقول ما توقعاتكم
نطاق العمليه التركيه في شمال سوريا
المرتقبه واسعه بينما توقع خمسه 55% ان
تكون محدوده النطاق هذا السؤال سيبقى
كالعاده مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخوله صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا تتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد هذه الليله في
سادس ايام مونديال قطر تعادل ايجابي بين
هولندا والاكوادور
والسنغال تنعش امالها في التاهل للدور
الثاني بعد فوزها على قطر
منتخب ايران يتغلب على نظيره الويلزي
بثنائيه في الدقائق الاخيره
وبعد الحصاد مباشره واحده وتحديدا في
الساعه الثانيه عشره وخمس دقائق بتوقيت
مكه المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه
اليوميه يوميات المونديال التي ترصد
بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر
[موسيقى]
هل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
بلاده تعمل على انشاء حزام امنيا على طول
حدودها الجنوبيه من الغرب الى الشرق وذلك
في اقرب وقت ممكن وقد نفى وزير الدفاع
التركي خلاص يا كار ان تكون القوات
التركيه قد استهدفت المدنيين او استهدفت
لقاتا تابعه لقوات التحالف خلال تنفيذ
العمليات العسكريه شماليه سوريه
لايام ام شهور اخر حدود العمليات العسكريه
التركيه في الشمال السوري لن تكون جغرافيه
فحسب التوغل البري وارد جدا ولكن دون
تاريخ محدد تريد انقر حزما امنيا من الغرب
الى الشرق والغرب الجويه المستمره منذ سته
ايام هدفها اقامه تلك المنطقه اوضح الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان العمليه البريه
الموعوده والمؤجره الى الوقت المناسب وفق
توقيت انقر السياسي والعسكري ستشمل تل
رفعت ومنبج وعين العرب كوباني اي استكمال
المنطقه الامنيه التي يبلغ عمقها 30 كلم
على طول الحدود الجنوبيه ومن كل منبر ترسل
تركيا رسائل وعيد جديده هذه المره فعاليه
في اسطنبول خاصه بمكافحه العنف ضد المراه
التي تريح الدماء في بلادنا وتقتل النساء
والاطفال هم شركاء في اراقه الدماء
والوحشيه التي تحصل والجرائم ضد الانسانيه
التي تركب
كفي تصريحاته بشان سير العمليه العسكريه
قال وزير الدفاع التركي خلوسي اكار ان
326 ارهابيا على حد تعبيره قتلوا في
الغارات الجويه والقذف المدفعي نفس اهدافه
القوه التركيه المدنيين او نقاطا تابعه
لقوه التحالف خلال تلك العمليه
طريق اوكار جاء ردا على حديث البنتاجون
الاربعاء الماضي عن تهديد العمليات
التركيه سلامه العسكريين الامريكيين في
شمال السوري بنظر واشنطن الوضع المتساعد
يعرض للخطر ما تسميه التقدم الذي تحقق على
مدى سنوات ضد تنظيم الدوله يوجد حاليا
قرابه 900 جندي امريكي في سوريا تحديدا في
شمالها الشرقي يعملون مع قوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه لمحاربه فلول تنظيم الدوله
مخاوف وعشان
قد لا تغير شيئا في خطط انقر الحاليه
والمستقبليه عن عمليه عسكريه الاوسع يتحدث
المسؤولون هذه المره يحرصون على التذكير
ان تامين الحدود عن طريق ممر امنيا لن
يتعارضاني وحده اراضي كل من سوريا والعراق
كان فيما تسمى وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
ضلوعها في تفجير شارع الاستقلال باسطنبول
نفيون تنفيه انقره عين التركيه على عين
العرب كوباني هل التوغل البري مساله ايام
فقط
الى شمال سوريا
لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ان
العمليات العسكريه الحاليه تهدد العمل
المشترك ضد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
ينضم الينا الان من اسطنبول غورجن زنكين
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومعنى من باريس
كدار بيري مدير مؤسسه الكرد بلا حدود اهلا
بضيفينا نبدا بضيفنا من اسطنبول السيد
زنكن هل هذه العمليه التي اشار اليها
الرئيس اردوغان تبدو وشيكه
القوات
عواصم مثل موسكو وغيرها
ويمكن ان تحدث في اي لحظه لكن كما قلت
[موسيقى]
القوات المسلحه التركيه جاهزه تماما هذا
الاختبار الذي تشير اليه ربما جاء في لقاء
وزير الدفاع مع سفيري الولايات المتحده
وروسيا
وهذان البلدان يبدوان معترضين على هذه
العمليه ما العمل في هذه الحاله
سمسم
[موسيقى]
عندما يتعلق الامر
بالهجمات الارهابيه في سوريا او في تركيا
الجيش موجود
واذا استمرت الهجمات فيمكن ان يكون هناك
عمليه ضد مصادر تلك الهجمات
انقر سيد جدا تقول انها اتفقت عديد المرات
على ضروره تراجع همم القوات وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكردي الى حدود تقريبا 30 كم همم
عن الحدود و لم يحصل وبالتالي فهي مجبره
كما تقول على هذه العمليه ما قولكم
لا حقيقه الامر الذي تم الاتفاق عليه قد
حصل لابتعاد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مسافه
30 كيلو متر عن الحدود التركيه لكن الطرف
الذي لم يلتزم هو تركيا وتلك المناطق التي
كانت تتعرض بالقصف بشكل يومي منذ عام 2019
حتى قبل ذلك ايضا عندما تم احتلال مدينه
عفرين حيث المنطقه الامن الذي كان يتحدث
عنها الرئيس التركي التي تحولت الى منطقه
قتل واجرام حيث الخطف حيث تهجير
الديمقراطي حيث التوطين همم
المجموعات الارهابيه همم يعني دائما
الاتحام من طرف تركيا موجه لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بحجه حمايه حدودها والحقيقه
بان كل العالم يترك حتى الدوله التركيه
وكل استخباراتها واعلامها لم يؤكد مره
واحده بانه تم اطلاق او هجوم بري او اي
شيء من قبل قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تجاه
الدوله
تسمح لي السيد بيري اذا كان الامر كذلك
اذا كان الامر كذلك ما الذي يدفع تركيا
الى القيام بعمليه طالما انه لا يوجد
تهديد حقيقي لانها هي تقول العمليه
الارهابيه الاخيره في اسطنبول دبرت في
عفرين ربما هذا اخر تطور
لا اخر التطورات عن تلك العمليه التي دبرت
من قبل
الخفيه بان تلك الفتاه احلام البشير هي
غير كرديه وانما سوريا من سوريا من حلب او
من اصول فلسطينيه ثلاثه من اشقائها قتلوا
على يد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه احدهم في
منبج كانوا ينتمون الى تنظيم داعش والاخر
همم في الرقه الثالث في مدينه الموصل على
يد القوات العراقيه والرابع ما زال قائدا
لدى فصيل الجيش في الجيش الوطني التابع
لتركيا تلك الفتاه تزوجت ثلاث مرات من من
عناصر ل 11 حيث يقتل وتتزوج من الثاني اذا
تلك العمليه من تدبير الاستخبارات التركيه
وليست في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه او حتى
لحزب العمال والكردستاني اي اعمال مشابهه
مثل هذه العمليه
يعني بعد اذنك لنرى ما يقول السيد زينكن
في هذا الموضوع لانه اذا اذا فعلا هذه
الصوره حقيقيه تصبح المستندات التي تعتمد
عليها انقره ضعيفه
نعم السؤال للسيد
249 هجوم على الاراضي التركيه في 2021
328 هجوما جاء من حزب بيكيكي
والهذه المجموعه
في 2020 هذا العام 350 هجوما جاءت بنت تلك
الجهه هذه هجمات ارهابيه من الاراضي
السوريه على الاراضي التركيه
وفي تلك المنطقه التي تم انشائها اذا
الهجمات موجوده
وهم يقومون بالكثير منها فيما يتعلق
بالقوات
الديمقراطيه السوريه
هذه احزاب
كرديه معترف بها من قبل الولايات المتحده
منذ عام 1997 كانت تعتبر منظمات ارهابيه
لكن من اجل دعمها في الاراضي السوريه
غيروا الاسم في كيكي
هذه مسميات تحول اسمها الى قوات
الديمقراطيه سوريه واذا تغيرت الاسماء
تغيرت هل يغير الطبيعه على الارهابيه لهذه
المجموعه
التي اشار اليها ضيفنا من باريس والتي
تقول بانها كل ما بنت عليه تركيا همم
موقفها غير صحيح
من يقول انها غير صحيحه
الذين
قاموا
بالقنابل والانفجارات وقتلوا كثير منهما
اكثر من 81 مصابا كان من
بيكيكيات التي اثرت اليها عندما يتحدث
الرئيس اردوغان عن عمليه في اقرب وقت ممكن
ما توقعاته
استاذ محمد فقط قناتكم قناه الجزيره هي
اضخم واكبر قناه ناطقه باللغه العربيه هل
وثقتم مره واحده بان كان هناك هجوم من قبل
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه باتجاه تركيا
اعتقد بانه لا وانا اكثر المتابعين لكم
نقطه انتهى هنا موضوع حزب العمال
الكردستاني دعونا من حزب العمال
والكردستاني ذاك شان تركي داخلي وعلى تركي
الالتفاف الى الوضع الداخلي وحل القضيه
القضيه التي تتعلق بحزب العمال الكردستاني
وانما تتعلق بقضيه شعب قاتل على ارضه
يطالب بحقوقه تاريخيه على ارضه يطالب بحل
ديمقراطي داخل جمهوريه التركيه هل ينعم به
ينعم سلام يلعن به كل كل القاطنين الاتراك
والعرب والكرد معا داخل تركيا اما عن
الهجوم التركي انساهم الرئيس التركي او
للدوله التركيه الان الهجوم لفعلتها قبل
عده ايام سنح لهم اليوم سيفعلهم وان غدا
نحن نتعرف لعمليه الافاده عراقيه حقيقيه
في تلك المنطقه
الموضوع لا يتعلق بتقسيم اصبح عنوان عنوان
الحمله العسكريه البربريه الان اصبح
عنوانها اقامه منطقه امنه من الشرق الى
الغرب وقبل عده ايام قبل ثلاثه ايام كانوا
يقولون بانها انتقام لما حصل في تقسيم من
عمل الارهابي وهو فعل فعلا على الارهابي
الموضوع التخبطت السياسه الاتراك الوضع
الانتخابيه التلبي يؤثر على سياساتها
الخارجيه يريدون تصدير ازمتهم الداخليه
الى الخارج ودائما الضحيه تكون
يعني قوات سوريا او الكرت في تلك المنطقه
ما نطمح اليه حل سياسي عادل شامل لكامل
المنطقه الحل القضيه الكرديه داخل سوريا
والقضيه الكليه داخل تركيا دوله تركيا
ديمقراطيه تفضل شكرا لك من باريس اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
كرتون
محور القتال الابرز والاكثر ضراوه في
اوكرانيا اما على الصعيد المواقف
والتصريحات تتبادل موسكو جمله من
الاتهامات
ورغبه غير معلنه في عدم الوصول الى اي
تسويه سلميه وبين تراشق موسكو
الدخول على الخط تاكيد على دعم اوكرانيا
بعد اسبوعين من انسحابها من مقاطعه خيرسون
تعود القوات الروسيه الى تركيز هجومها على
المقاطعه التي تعرضت لقصف مكثف استهدف
اكثر من 23 قريه على طرفي نهر النيترو برو
وذكر الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
قصفت المقاطعه تسعه واربعين مره خلال
الساعه الماضيه وفي نيكولايف تحدثت سلطات
المدينه عن قصف روسي استهدف منشات البنيه
التحتيه الخاصه بالمياه والكهرباء كما
استهدفت المدفعيه الروسيه مدينه نيكول
الواقعه في مقاطعه
القذائف وفقا للجيش الاوكراني وعلى الجانب
الروسي اعلنت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
مقاطعه دونتس سقوط قتلى وشرح
الاوكراني في الساعات الماضيه كما اعلنت
موسكو توجيها ضربات الى نقاط ينتشر بها من
سمتهم مرتزقه بولنديين في هاتي خاركيف
شماليه اوكرانيا
وبالتوازي مع احتدام القتال بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه يوصل حلف شمال
الاطلسي بعث رسائل داعمه لكيف مفادها عدم
تراجع دول الحلف عن تسليم اوكرانيا ما
يمكنها من التصدي للقوات الروسيه موسكو
معظم الحروب تنتهي بمفاظات لكن ما يحدث
على طاوله المفاوضات يعتمد على ما يقعوا
في ميدان المعركه ولذلك فان افضل السبل
لتعزيز فرص التوصل الى حلل سلمي دعم
اوكرانيا فنيته سيواصل تضامنه مع اوكرانيا
ما استغرق ذلك من وقت
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي وصف الدعم
المقدم الى كيف بغير المسبوق وانه سيطلب
المزيد من الدعم وسط تمديد دوليا على
استهداف القوات الروسيه للبنيه التحتيه
الحيويه وهو ما وصفته المندوبه الامريكيه
لدى الامم المتحده بالتصعيد المخجل في حرب
وحشيه غير مبرره
هذا قد كلام متحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه
الى برلين تبحث مع حلفائها طلبك هولندا
تزويد اوكرانيا بوحده النظام الدفاع الجوي
باتريوت التي كانت مخصصه لها وفي سياقه
الدعم الغربي لاوكراني قال وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني جيمس ليفرليه ان بريطانيا تقدم
دعمها بالافعال وليس بالاقوال فقط
يعاني قطاع الطاقه الاوكرانيه من مشاكل
عده نتيجه تعرضي بنيته التحتيه لقصف
الروسي من وقت الى اخر وتواصل السلطات
الاوكرانيه وعملها لايصال الكهرباء الى
جميع المشتركين الذين انقطعت عنهم الخدمه
ويعيشوا اهالي كيف ظروف واستثنائيه جراء
الانقطاعات المتكرره للتيار الكهربائي في
مدينتهم وهما فرض عليهم ان نمط حياه جديده
لترشيد استهلاك الكهرباء
احدى الاسواق الرئيسيه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف
يخيم الظلام على محل السوق نتيجه انقطاع
الكهرباء وتصبح الشموع واجهزه الطاقه
الاحتياطيه البديله الوحيده المتاح
انخفض دخلنا بسبب انقطاعات الكهرباء نقدي
وقتنا في التحضير والانتظار
مع كل هجمه روسيه على محطات الطاقه في
اوكرانيا تزداد فترات انقطاع الكهرباء
وتقنينها في عاصمه بلاد كانت مصدرا لها
وجزءا من امن الطاقه الاوروبي
يسابق عمال الصيانه الزمن لاعاده التيار
الكهربائي الى المناطق المتضرره ويتجاوب
كثيرا من سكان العاصمه مع طلب السلطات
ترشيد استهلاكهم لتخفيف الضغط على نظام
الطاقه الاوكراني المتضرر جر الحرب
عمال الصيانه والمواطنون واصحاب المهن
والاعمال التجاريه كل شخص منهم يقوم بدوره
بدعم قطاع الطاقه فهذه مهمه وطنيه
لطبيب يقول انها عمليه جراحيه هجريه لقلب
طفل في اثناء استهداف صاروخيا ادى الى
انقطاع الطاقه عن غرفه
اما هذا المشفى فهو يسعى لتوفير ظروف جيده
للمرضى عبر ضمان استمراريه الخدمات ولو
بادنى استهلاك للطاقه
هناك تحذيرات من وزاره الصحه باننا قد
نتعرض للانقطاعات في المياه والكهرباء
لذلك اصبحت لدينا قواعد نعمل بها في حاله
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وتدربت كوادرنا
على ذلك
تساعد مواطنينها فيما لو استمر استهدافه
قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
اسست السلطات الاوكرانيه في عموم البلاد
اماكن كهذه جهزتها بمصادر للطاقه غير
مرتبطه بشبكه الكهرباء العامه وذلك لتامين
الطاقه والتدفئه للسكان في حال طالت مده
انقطاع الكهرباء هي ظروف استثنائيه يعيشها
مواطنون في ظل حرب طال امدها ظروف ستبقى
في ذاكرتي من ينجون منها لوقت طويل
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره كيف
ستكون لنا وقفه اخرى مع شان الاوكراني حيث
نتناول مع ضيفنا في فقره في المتابعه
التطورات الميدانيه الجديده ودلالاتها
[موسيقى]
الى اسرائيل الان حيث اتفاق الاولي
للاعتلاف مهد الطريق لتشكيل حكومه العائد
الى رئاسه الوزراء
الاتفاق وابرمه نتنياهو مع رئيس حزب
العظمه اليهوديه اتمار بن غفير يتولى
بموجبه هذا الاخير وزاره الامن الداخلي في
اسرائيل خطوه قبلت بتحذيرات من تصعيد
الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه
بالنظري للسجل بن غفير الحافلي بالانشطه
الاستفزازيه للفلسطينيين التي كان يقود
فيها يهودا متطرفين
الخانه
يبتغي في الحكومه الاسرائيليه وزاره الامن
الداخلي
بين حزب اليكود وحزب العظمه اليهوديه الذي
راسه بني كثير ليمهد ذلك الطريق لحكومه
نتنياهو من اجل ان ترنر وزاره الامن
الداخلي في اسرائيل هيئه اركان المشتركه
بقرار من الحكومه تم تغيير اسمها عام
1995 بعدما كان وزاره الشرطه
وهي المسؤوله عن تطبيق القانون والحفاظ
على النظام العام وكل ما يتعلق بالامن
الداخلي حيث تعمل عبر اجهزه مختلفه هي
شرطه اسرائيل ومصلحه السجون وسلطه حمايه
الشهود وسلطه مكافحه المخدرات والكحول
لكننا نتنياهو يريدها بصلاحيات اوسع فقد
اضاف اليها اداره شرطه حرس الحدود في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله
نالت هذه صلاحيات رضا بني كثير الذي علق
على اتفاقه مع اللي كود قائلا ان حزبه حصل
على الادوات اللازمه لاعاده الامن
للاسرائيليين والاهتمام بالسكان في الجليل
والنقب والضواحي لكن اتفاق بكثير نتنياهو
لم يلقى ترحيب لدى وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي قال ان الفكره من وراء ما جرى لاتفاق
عليه بينهما هي خلق جيش خاص لبني كثير في
الضفه الغربيه على نحو يشكل خطوره على
تفعيل قوات الجيش ويخلق مشاكل امنيه
حقيقيه وصفها بانها اشبه بعمليه ارهابيه
ومثل ذلك تخشى السلطه الفلسطينيه فحسب
بيان لوزاره الخارجيتها فان صلاحيات التي
يمنحها نتنياهو لبن كفيره ستكون لها
انعكاسات على اي جهود اقليميه ودوليه تبذل
من اجل التهدئه
[موسيقى]
الاتفاق المثير للجدل بين اللكود وحزب
العظمه اليهوديه يمنح حزب بني كثير ايضا
رئاسه لجنه الامن الداخلي بالكنيست ومنصب
نائب وزير الاقتصاد وتضمن ايضا تسويه
الوضع القانوني ل 65 بؤره الشيطانيه
عشوائيه في الضفه الغربيه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بشكل قد يكون غير
مسبوقه فيثمار بن كثير نفسه ودين عام 2007
بالتحديد العنصري ضد العرب ودعم جماعه
تعتبرها الولايات المتحده منظمه ارهابيه
لقد كان الرجل معارضا بشراسه
فلسطينيه وشهد خلال الحمله الدعائيه
للانتخابات وهو يلوح ببندقيه في اتجاه
متظاهرين فلسطين في القدس الشرقيه
معنى من تل ابيب الدكتور الدان شيفتان
رئيس مركز دراسات الامن القومي بجامعه
حيفا لنبدا مما قاله وزير الدفاع جانس قال
هذا الاتفاق يجعل من رئيس الحكومه الحقيقي
هو من غفير هل هذا صحيح
لكن لا يؤخذ على محمل الجد يعني هذا وزير
دفاع يعني ليس مواطنا عاديه عندما يقول
وزير الدفاع هذا الكلام يجب ان يؤخذ بجديه
يعني مبسوطه
بين كل شيء يقوله
سياسه ولا اعتقد انه لا ينبغي ان نعطيه
اهميه كبيره
شخصيه محترمه ويمكن ان تكون
مسؤوله في حكومه
هو نتيجه واقع
كونه هناك
نسبه كبيره من
لهجه الحاده
وقد بدا من قبل عام ونصف في ماي 2021 عند
العرب تظاهره ضد اليهود وحصلوا على دعم من
قياداتهم السياسيه وما لدينا هو عنف عربي
عندما
يتعرض الامر يتعلق الامر
بالزراعه وغيرها كثيرون يقولون واعتقد
انهم محقون ان
الشرطه الاسرائيليه ضعيفه ووزاره الدفاع
ضعيفه
والقضاه ايضا وهذا ما جعل بن كثير هل
سيكون خ انا ليكون وزيرا لا هل سيغير ذلك
اسرائيل بشكل عميق لا لكن من ناحيه
تاريخيه هو يمثل المشكله لكنه قد لا يكون
مشكله كبيره
والان سوف نرى ان كان سيعيد المزيد من
الامن الى اسرائيل يعني حتى ولو اعاد
الامن همم رجل مثله متهم بالارهاب ومن
محاكم اسرائيليه
اليهم عديده ولا احبها ولا لا احب ما كان
يفعله
لكنه لديه دعم وسوف يتم اختباره باعماله
لا اعتقد انه يمكن ان يذهب بعيدا لانه
هناك
مراقبه سياسيه همم بين القوه السياسيه
المختلفه وهناك الراي العام هل من الذي
سيسمح بالراي العام الاسرائيلي وتوقع هو
انه سيكون سيجد صعوبات ولكنها ليست صعوبات
كبيره ليست كبيره حتى وان كانت واشنطن
الدول الاوروبيه ستتحفظ على هذا الرجل
تحديدا
الاوروبين
اسرائيل لا تحب ذلك بالنسبه ل واشنطن
اعتقد ان واشنطن كانت قلقه جدا
شخصيه اخرى اصبح وزير دفاع ولم يحدث ذلك
وعندما يتعلق الامر بالعلاقات الخارجيه
بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده فانا موقف
واشنطن مهم جدا
وعندما يتعاقد الامر بالشرطه الاسرائيليه
والنظام القضائي همم اسرائيلي لا اعتقد ان
الامريكيين سوف يفرضون همم ضغوتا كبيره
دعني اكرر مره اخرى
كوزير للدفاع سمارت رينج ال الضغط
الامريكي كان حاسما
ولكن الامر
هذا امر اذا جدي
من تل ابيب شكرا جزيلا
نظام الين الان من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور ما الذي
ينتظر الفلسطينيين
جراء هذا الاتفاق
عندما ياتي نتنياهو بفاشي ارهابي مثل بن
كبير لوزاره الامن فهو يلعب بالنار
بالتاكيد
ليس لانه جيش الاحتلال لم يكن ارهابيا
طوال الوقت وكذلك دوله اسرائيل ولكنه يضيف
الى صفه الارهاب الان الارهاب الفاسي وهذا
امر في غايه الخطوره وفعلا وهو يلعب
بالنار هذا الذي عينوه وزيرا للامن هو
نفسه لم يسمعه له بانخدم في الجيش
الاسرائيلي بسبب تطرفه
لا يعرفها الكثيرون وهو خطه التي وضعها
الان تتضمن تعديل عن تعليمات اطلاق النار
بحيث يفتح المجال الحرس الحدود وجيش
الاحتلال والشرطه ان تطلق النار بحريه على
الفلسطينيين وان يمنحهم حصانه على عمليات
اطلاق النار وان يوفر اسلحه للمسرحين من
الشرطه والجيش وهم بالاضافه لذلك يريد ان
يمنع اي وجود فلسطين في في 62% من الضفه
الغربيه اي مناطق جيم ويريد ان يشدد
القبضه على الاسرى الفلسطينيين في السجون
الاحتلال هاي خطوه
ذلك انه صلاحيات التي منحت له تعني انه
ستكون له اليد الطولا فيما يجري في المسجد
الاقصى الذي وصل الاستفزازات فيه قبل ان
يكون وزيرا وكذلك في اتجاه فلسطيني الداخل
وتجاه النقب والجليل واتجاه طبعا كل سكان
الضفه الغربيه نحن نتحدث عن تطور في غايه
الخطوره لا يرعبنا هذا التطور ولكن يجب ان
يؤك ضروره الاسراع في توحيد كل
الفلسطينيين في مواجهه هذا الخطر الفاشي
وايضا الاسراع في اتخاذ كل الخطوات لعزل
هذه الحكومه الفاشيه المتطرفه
ولتصنيف هذا الحزب وبنج فير كارهابي في كل
العالم هذا ما هو المطلوب لان القادم امر
في غايه الخطوره هل يمكن ان تكون رب ضاره
النافعه بمعنى ان على الفلسطينيين ان
يواجهوا هذا الاحتلال بوجهه الحقيقي
المكشوف دون ايت اوهام بين تشكيله وزاريه
واخرى
بالتاكيد واول الاوهام التي يجب القائها
يعني خارجه الساحه الفلسطينيه هي الوهم
بامكانيه التفاوض مع هؤلاء المجرمين
والوهم بامكانيه وجود حل وسط مع الحركه
الصهيونيه في ظل هذا الاختلال الفضيع في
ميزان القوه والوهم بان الولايات المتحده
ستتدخل لتفرد عمليه سلميه هذه الاوهام يجب
ان تنتهي واليوم الوحده الفلسطينيه يجب ان
تكون على
نهج وطني كفاحي مقاوم هؤلاء لا يفهموا الى
لغه القوه ولا يمكن صد ارهاب غير القادم
والارهاب الفاسي لان نتنياهو حكومته الا
بالمقاومه والكفاح وتوحيد الصف الوطني
بالعمل على عزل ومقاطعه اسرائيل والعمل
على عزل ومقاطعه هؤلاء الى ارهابيين الذين
لا يخجلوا من اعلاناتهم المتكرره هذا
الرجل لسه يجعلونه وزير امل يعلق صوره
جولد شتاين فاروق جولد شتايم الذي ارتكب
المجزره في حلبه الابراهيمي في مكتبه نحن
نتحدث فعلا عن صفه ارهابيه فاشيه بالمعنى
الحرفي للكلمه
افتتاحيه صحيفه هاردز الاسرائيليه اليوم
قالت بان ما يجري هو خطوه اخرى نحو همم في
اتجاه الدم هل هذا ممكن
انا اعتقد ان هذه هي الخطه الحقيقيه ليس
فقط لبن كثير وانما لان نتنياه نفسه
وسميترتش ولذلك شجعهم على ان يتوحدوا لكي
يحصلوا على الاصوات اللازمه وهذه هي الخطه
الحقيقيه لان نتنياهو التي اعلنها مرارا
وتكرارا او اخفاها احيانا خطته الحقيقيه
تم الضفه الغربيه والخطر في هذه السياسه
التي يعلنها بين كبيرنا هي انهم يحلم
بتطهير عراقيه جديد للشعب الفلسطيني كما
شارع في عام 48 وطبعا خطتهم عندما يشرع
البؤر الاستيطانيه التي انشاها المستوطنون
بالاضافه الى المستوطنات القائمه ماذا
يعني ذلك يعني عمليه ضم فعلي للضفه
الغربيه ومحاوله لوضع الفلسطينيين في ظروف
قاسيه على امل ان يتم تهجرهم هم مخطئون
تماما لانه الذي يجري كما قلت حضرتك وهذا
صحيح اخر محمد هذا يكشف الوجه الحقيقي
لاسرائيل ويمنحن فرصه ممتازه لتوحيد الصف
الوطني الان على ما هي على الحقيقه واقفه
امامنا وهي ان هذه حكومه ارهاب وحكومه
فاشيه ويمنحنا الفرصه للعمل على عزملها
لذلك انا انظر لهذا الامر باعتباره فرصه
الان لتوحيد الفلسطينيين على نهج وطني
كفاحي مقاوم في مواجهه هذا الخطر الفاشل
القادم شكرا لك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من
رام الله
[موسيقى]
انا سلطات البنزليه
على توقيع اتفاق سيتيح وتحرير موارد بني
زوليه مجمده في الخارج وذلك من اجل تمويل
المشاريع الاجتماعيه في فاتحه استئناف
المفاوضات بين الطرفين يوم السبت في
المكسيك
المعارضه
على برنامج المساعدات الانسانيه
التي تعاني من ظروف الانسانيه بالغه
التعقيد وكذلك على شروط الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقرر اجرائها بعد عامين تقول
الحكومه اين المفاوضات ستجرى على مستوى
جديد وفي نقطتين جديده وانها ستوقع السبت
اتفاقا مع المعارضه سيتيح تحرير موارد
فنزويليه مجمده في الخارج من اجل تمويل
مشاريع اجتماعيه وهو ما شدد عليه المعارضه
قائله ان الاتفاق ذو طابع الاجتماعيه ومن
شان عوده الطرفين الى المفاوضات المعلقه
منذ اكتوبر من العام الماضي ان تؤدي الى
رفع التجميد عن مليارين و700 مليون دولار
من الودائع في الحسابات الدوليه وينتظر
استخدامها باشراف الامم واحده في تموين
مشاريع تتعلق باعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه
في البدايه
الرئيس الفنزويلي نيكولاسما دورو عدو
الولايات المتحده اللدود استبق المفاوضات
المتوقعه بشكر الوسطاء من النرويج وفرنسا
والمكسيك وركز على ان الاتفاقيه المتوقعه
ستبرم بين الفنز والايين ومن اجلهم
علينا وضع الامور في مكانها وسائل الاعلام
المهيمنه في الغرب والولايات المتحده
والحكومه الاجنبيه لن تفرض اي شيء على
فنزويلا اليوم ولا في اي وقت على الاطلاق
اسمعوني جيدا لن يفرض علينا احد اي شيء
اليوم وغدا وابدا ابدا
زعيم المعارضه البارز الذي يحظى بدعم
الولايات المتحده يقول ان المعارضه تعول
كثيرا على مفاوضات المكسيك ويعتبرها افضل
خيار ويرى ان اي فشل يصاحبها سيزيد الازمه
سوءا وتطالب المعارضه التي تتهم الرئيس
بتزوير انتخابات عام 2018 بجدول زمني
انتخابي جديد ومتفق عليه وعلى مختلف
مستوياته وصولا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقرره عام 2024 مع ضمانتي بشان شرعيه
التصويت فضلا عن الافراد عن سجناء
السياسيين
الينا من العاصمه الفنزويلا كركاس ايزابيل
الفرنجيه الكبيره في شان الفنزويلي اهلا
وسهلا بيك سيدي في البدايه اشرح لنا كيف
هذا الاتفاق بين الحكومه والمعارضه يسمح
برفع التجميد على اموال فنزويليه
فيما يختص هذا الاجتماع
عده اجتماعات وكانت تواصل الى رفع
العقوبات كان شرطاسيه من قبل الدوله او
الحكومه بالنسبه ليا على اساس التقدم في
على طاوله الحوار بالنسبه الى ان في
الماضي توقفت همم
يعني اختطاف
بما تعني به همم الدوله بالنسبه
للعقبات اذا همم اليوم همم اي حوار داخلي
في فنزويلا لا يسمح ويفتح الطريق الى همم
الى فتح همم طريق امام رفع العقوبات عن
همم اصول
او وضعت في امانه هون الذي كانت تعترف به
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كرئيسا شرعيا
فنزويلا انما طورت الحوار اليوم اااه تضع
من اولويات هذه هذه المبادره ان يكون هناك
رفع الحصار عن هذه الاموال او اصول
بالنسبه لي
تحصين ولتحسين الوضع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
الداخلي في بنزله طبعا في خضم هذه
الطاوله طويله الحوار همم مرتبطه بما يحدث
في امريكا اللاتينيه ودوليه اولها علاقه
اعاده العلاقات مع كلهمبياء التي هي اليوم
همم
الراعي ل همم وداعم لهذه الخطوه الاساسيه
طبعا ايضا المكسيك وهنا اليوم الانتخابات
التي حصلت البرازيل وبالتالي ما يحصل
دوليا
على من الولايات المتحده ان تخفف نوعا ما
اا حددت همم
يعني
التباعد مع كركاس وبالتالي فتح مجال امامه
شابرون وامام همم
شركات همم شركات امريكيه في استخراج النفط
اما في الاستثمار في بنات ولا اذا نرى نحن
من خلال كل هذه الامور التي تحصل بانه
هناك يعني نوعا ما من من تليين هذه
العلاقات ما بين همم جميع الاطراف التي
تسمح بن نوعا ما بان تكون همم المعارضه
الفلزات تجبر نوعا ما اقول على همم على
الموافقه لعده امور همم كانت علقه سابقا
فبالتالي اليوم وضعك وليس لم لم يعد كما
السابق يعني جويده همم كان يحصل لدعم دولي
دعم مطلق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اليوم بمجرد ما تكون الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
تجلس على طاوله حوار حوار يعني بديل مع
الحكومه البنسلين مباشره وبالتالي ان تسمح
تسمح هدف بالتالي هذا ما يكون يخفض نوعا
ما من قوه او وجود
عليه الطاولات حلوه
[موسيقى]
في تونس انطلقت الحملات وادعائيه
للانتخابات التشريعيه المسمع اجراءها في
السابعه عشر من ديسمبر المقبل واستدعوات
من الاحزاب وهيئات المعارضه لمقاطعه هذا
الاقتراع وقد حضر خبراء في هيئاته مراقبه
الانتخابات من عزوف الناخبين على المشاركه
في التصويت بعد الغاء المنافسه الحزبيه
وفرض نظام الاقتراعي على الافراد
رغم انطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه لم تبرز بعد
ملامح التنافس بين المرشحين للمجلس
النيابي المقبل في من حاصر النقاش وفي
مواقع التواصل حمله قد يتغيروا ايقاعها
خلال الاونه المقبله وقد تعكس طبيعه
المرحله السياسيه الحاليه هي مغامره او
جزء من المغامره التي دخل فيها الرئيس
سعيد وادخل البلاد فيها ولن نستطيع ان
نحكم عليها الان ولكن سنرى الى اين ستقود
المهم الان ان الجزء الواسع من الطبقه
السياسيه سيكون خارج هذا هذه الانتخابات
الخارج
انتخابات تشريعيه تجرى بعد اكثر من عام
على الاجراءات الاستثنائيه لسعيه
العمل بالمراسيم الرئاسيه كما حل البرلمان
بشكل رسمي بعد تجميده لاشهر
ثم عرض دستور جديد على الاستفتاء صديق
عليه باكثر من 90%
ويتنافس في هذه الانتخابات 1055 مترشحا
على 261 مقعدا في البرلمان وفقا قانون
الانتخابيه قائما على الافراد بدل القوائم
الحزبيه
والمره الاولى في استحقاق الانتخابيه
تشريعيه لم تشهد عشر دوائر انتخابيه حضور
اي مترشح الرزنامه التي قام بها الرئيس
التي كانت يوم 25
سبتمبر كانت يعني
وسوف نعود ان شاء الله يوم 17 ديسمبر الى
الشرعيه
تقاطع هذه الانتخابات ابرز الاحزاب التي
كانت في السلطه او تلك التي قادت المعارضه
كجبه الخلاص الوطنيه المكونه من حركه
النهضه وحزب قلب تونس واطراف سياسيه اخرى
اضافه الى الحزب الدستوريه الحر وحزبي
افاقي تونس مقاطعه يرونها موقفا من مسار
انقلابي لا يمكن ان يفضي الى ديمقراطيه
حقيقيه
في مسار 25
معناها الانتخابي غير متوفر الحاله
الانتخابيه للشاهدناها في اكثر من ثمانيه
مواعيد انتخابيه من 2011 لليوم هي مفقوده
قبل لا تعرف الحمله الانتخابيه ولا حتى
الانتخابات التشريعيه نفس الزخم الذي
عرفته التجارب السابقه الا ان اجراء
الانتخابات في مواعيدها يمثل رهانا مهما
بالنسبه الى داعميه الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
التي اتخذها الرئيس قيس سعيد
اسابيع قليله تفصيل تونسيين عن موعد
الانتخابات التشريعيه قد لا تغير نتائجها
الطبيعه الازمه ولا عمق الصراع الدائري
بين الرئيس و خصومه ازمه مركبه شملت جميع
مناحي الحياه سيف الدين بوعالج الجزيره
تونس
[موسيقى]
عوده الى التطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
وهذا التصعيد في القصف الروسي خلال ساعه
الماضيه مدينه خيرسون في جنوب اوكرانيا
تعرضت هي ومناطق اخرى في المقاطعه لقصف
الروسي المتواصل دفع السلطات الى المرضى
من المستشفيات المدينه التي انسحبت منها
القوه الروسيه قبل اسبوعين نضل في الجنوب
في جنوب اوكرانيا حيث تحدثت سلطاته مدينه
بيكو لايف عن قصف روسي استهدف منشات
البنيه التحتيه الخاصه بالمياه والكهرباء
جنوب ايضا دائما في منطقه الجنوب استهدفت
المدفعيه الروسيه مدينه نيكولا الواقعه في
مقاطعه فجر اليوم بعشرات القذائف وفقا
للجيش الاوكراني وفي مقاطعه دونيت هذه
المره اعلنت سلطات المواليه لروسيا سقوط
قتلى وجرحى قصف الاوكراني في الساعه
الماضيه تصعد القصف يتزامن مروري تسعد
اشهر على بدء روسيا ما سمته بعمليه عسكريه
خاصه بينما تقول اوكرانيا والغرب ان ما
يحدث هو غزو وحرب عدوانيه غير مبرر لكن ما
هي اضرار احدث جولات هذا القصف الروسي
نحو نصف سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه بقوا
محرومين من التيار الكهربائي اليوم بسبب
استهداف في روسيا منشات حيويه كيف التي
تعيش او يعيشوا فيها ملايين بدون كهرباء
تشهد وتساقطا للامطار الجليديه فيما تقارب
الحراره درجه الصفر وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قالت ان قصفها لم يستهدف كير واتهمت
المضادات الجويه الاوكرانيه بالمسؤوليه عن
الاضرار التي لحقت بالمدينه لكن واقع
الحال انه منذ منتصف تشرين الاول اكتوبر
عمد روسيا الى توجيه ضربات لمنشات الطاقه
الاخرانيه وقد دفع ذلك منظمه الصحه
العالميه الى التحرير من تداعيات مميته
احيانا وفق تعبيرها لملايين الاوكرانيين
الذين قد يهجرون منازلهم بحثا عن الدفئ
والامن
انضموا الينا الان من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا
وسهلا بك حضره العميد الان التركيز كله
تقريبا على القصف قصف روسي قصف اوكراني
اهميه القصف في حديث العمليات الجاريه
حاليا
محمد بعد الانسحاب من خرسان اصبحت خرسان
المدينه
احدى الجبهات الاساسيه
والفاصل بينها وبين الضفه الشرقيه حيث
يتواجد الجيش الروسي الفاصل هو نهر
النيبرو او نيبر بعد تفجير الجسور التي
تصل القطاعين ببعضهم البعض المرحله
الحاليه او المرحله المستقبليه في هذه
المنطقه هي دفاعيه بحته خاصه انه لا يمكن
للقوات الروسيه تجميع مراكز ثقل معينه من
قيادات وسيطره ومخازن ذخيره وحتى ابونا
تحتيه مهمه بسبب تواجد
من هنا همم المرحله القادمه هي مرحله
الدفاع في الجنوب ومرحله هجوم في الشرق ان
كان في ازماتور او في كريمينا او حتى في
مخموت عله يحقق الجيش الروسي اي تقدم خاصه
في محمود ولكن عندما يتم التركيز على
القصف تحديدا
اسلوب في ال- في الحرب ماجد الحربيه
بالمعنى العسكري البحت
اليوم بخيرسون المعنى هو تدميري المعنى هو
منع قيام جبهه مهمه في هذه المنطقه عله في
المرحله القادمه بعد الحديث عن محاوله
استرداد شبه جزيره الكرم وهذا امر مستبعد
لانه يتطلب جهد كبير جدا لمنع تشكل قوه
معينه ثابته قادره على عبور النهر ومن ثم
استرداد اولا كل الاقليم خرسان الاتجاه
شرقا باتجاه مليتوبول وقطع هذا الجسر
البري هي عمليه منع هذا هو المتوفر محمد
حاليا بالنسبه للجيش الروسي هو محاوله كسب
الوقت
لتحضير القوات العسكريه مع الاستدعاء مع
الاحتياط وحتى مع الخدمه الالزاميه
وبالتالي اعاده التشكيل وهذا امر مهما
الجيش الروسي اليوم هو بحاجه لوقت لاعاده
تنظيم القوى من هنا القصف على العمق
الاوكراني الطاقه والمياه والبنى التحتيه
فعلا هذا التركيز على البنوك تحتيه
الكهرباء والطاقه وغيرها هل تراه من
الناحيه العسكريه مساله مقصوده تحديدا
بالطبع محمد اصبحت استراتيجيه معينه لماذا
اولا لانها تكررت اثنين حجم القصف يدل ان
هناك استراتيجيه معينه المسيرات الايرانيه
شاهد 136 وحتى صواريخ الكلب فاذن هذا
الاستمرار لفتره طويله يهدف الى شيء معين
ضربه داخل ضربه القتال لانه مرتبطه مباشره
بالجبهات التي طول الجبهه 1000 كيلو متر
تقريبا وبالتالي اختبار الغرب ومدى دعمه
همم خلق ازمه ازمه لاجئين ولازحين
وبالتالي ضرب العزيمه الاساسيه هناك رد
اوروبيه يبدو في هذه المرحله تزويد
اوكرانيا بمولدات كهربائيه
كثيره جدا هناك 200 مولد قد يصل قريبا الى
اوكرانيا هل هذا اسلوب حربي ناجى بمعنى
عندما تستهدف البنيه التحتيه تخلق راي عام
على المؤسسه العسكريه حتى تتراجع او تراجع
حساباتها
استراتيجيه القصف الاستراتيجي ان كان
لالمانيا او حتى لليابان هذا الفعل هذا
القصف يقرب الشعب اكثر من حكومته ولكنه
امر اساسي نفذ سابقا ينفذ حاليا والهدف
منه هو تدمير البناء التحتيه وعدم جعل
الحكومه او الدوله الاوكرانيه دوله فاعله
قادره على الحياه اقتصاديا سياسيا وحتى
اجتماعيا حتى انه في العقل الروسي لا يوجد
ما يسمى باوكرانيا لا سياده لاوكرانيا
وكانها ليست موجوده هذا القصر ياتي في هذا
الايطار في النهايه هل تتوقع ان يستمر هذا
الاسلوب اسلوب القصف
بالطبع سيستمر لكسب الوقت تحضير للمرحله
القادمه دفاع في منطقه خرسون هجوم في
الشرق وبالتالي بانتظار ما قد يحققه
الرئيس بوتين من همم
اعداد العسكر والعتاب وتكديس مستهلك من
صغيره خاصه الذخيره الذكيه شكرا جزيلا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
بيروت متحدثا عن اخر التطورات في اوكرانيا
الاتيه ما هذا القصف الروسي المتوسط
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا موعد
استعراض اهم الانباء عبر العالم قبل
الانتقال الى ساعه من الرياضه في يوميات
المانيا
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
بلاده تعمل على انشاء حزام امنيا على طول
حدودها الجنوبيه في اقرب وقت ممكن واضاف
اردوغان ان الهدف من هذا الحزام سيكون
حمايه امن المواطنين الاتراك ومن يعيشون
في مناطقه
الامريكيه الخاص الى شمالي وشرق سوريا
نيكولا ان بلاده تعارض بشده العمل
العسكريه الذي يزعزع الاستقرار في سوريا
وان واشنطن لم توافق على الضربات التركيه
في سوريا والتي تهدد كما قال العمل
المشترك ضد تنظيم الدوله
مع استمرار القتال بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه على طرفين هارديني برو في خرسان
وتقارير عن سقوط قتلى قالت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه انها صدت اثنتي عشر محاوله
للتقدم من قبل القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه
ايدونتس ولجانس شرقيه البلاد وفي الوقت
الذي يعاني فيه ملايين الاوكرانيين من نقص
امدادات الطاقه بسبب القذف الروسي قال
الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده ستحقق اهدافها من
العمليه العسكريه
قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسي ينسى
سولتمبرغ ان الحلفه سلم اوكرانيا ما
يمكنها من التصدي للمسيرات ولن يتراجع عن
دعمها وشدد على انه لن يكون هناك سلام
دائم اذا انتصرت روسيا في اوكرانيا
طالب متحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه ان
برلين تبحث مع الحلفاء طلب بولندا تزويد
اوكرانيا بوحده نظام الدفاع الجوي باتريوت
التي كانت مخصصه لها وفي سياق الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا قال وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه جيمس كليفرليه ان بلاده تقدم
دعمها بالافعال لا بالاقوال فقط
اتفق حزب اللكود برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو
والحزب المعروف بالعظمه اليهوديه برئاسه
ادمار بن غفير على تشكيل حكومه يقودها
نتنياهو وسيتولى من غفير حقيبه الامن
الداخلي في الحكومه المرتقبه مع صلاحيات
واسعه تشمل اداره شرطه حرس الحدود في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله وقد حذر وزير
الدفاع الحليب بني جانس من ان الاتفاق
يشكل خطرا امنيا على اسرائيل
اذن بهذا نصل الى نهايه جولتنا الاخباريه
دمتم في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]